hello folks welcome to
rational science
we have a great day today we're going to
be talking about the neutron
allegedly a
uh
it's a neutral particle
we're gonna find out if that's true
today
whether that's
has any merit to it
but let's uh begin with the extinction
headlines
we always talk about extinction first
is
is humanity are humans going to become
extinct
like ever first that's the first
question we have to answer and then uh
very soon
we'll find out right okay here's a
headline that came out this week says
scientists think they've figured out
when the sun will explode
and kill us all
oh my god i hope it doesn't happen next
week you know i was planning on going
out
to the park
i hope it does so i hope sun takes a ton
it's time and
does it in a million years or so at
least
says the sun's life cycle will end as
soon as five billion years from now
so how is it going to kill us all
well the idea of the sun dying is scary
there's a chance humanity won't even be
around to experience it oh okay i
thought so
but he says the earth's oceans will be
vaporized by energy from the sun
etcetera etcetera okay and so but then
he says
at the time
the sun's brightness will also have
increased by around 10 percent there are
also other threats of climate change to
take into account as well
okay so i guess he's saying that if none
of that kills us then the sun kills us
okay
it says the future of the earth is grim
perhaps that's why so many people are so
focused on space travel and getting us
to
other planets
so uh people think they're going to
escape uh
the earth
so when the sun explodes we won't have
to be around here right we'll be in a
nicer
uh solar system i guess uh when that's
just beginning we just move over there
and not only would it allow humanity to
continue surviving but it would give us
a new home to go
to when the sun eventually dies
i think a lot of these people have a lot
of fantasy on their heads they've been
watching too much star trek they think
we're gonna go to another planet
and then they're talking about the sun
exploding and killing us
i don't think we'll be around by that
for sure
okay but that's my five cents worth i
think uh
human extinction is right around the
corner we're the last humans on earth
and these people are talking about the
sun exploding and killing us
okay in a billion years
okay another uh
similar
headline ukraine china and climate
change tag this doomsday clock holds at
100 seconds to midnight matching
riskiest view ever
yeah there's this uh well those who are
not aware of it there's the doomsday
clock
and it's been uh around since uh after
world war ii
and a lot of that had to do with uh
the atomic bombs
will we ever throw them again at each
other and so that's when they started
with uh
all this doomsday thing
uh-oh am i having trouble with uh
youtube
i hope i'm still on fellas
let me know because i got a message from
youtube here
okay
uh
let me know if you can see and hear me i
just got a
a warning message that something's wrong
let me know
i
i
check everything to be okay
so let me know as soon as you
can get your
so i get my bearings back
okay
okay well i don't know
okay thank you
okay let me continue here uh
said um
uh scientists you know these uh atomic
scientists in fact there's 11 nobel
laureates
among them and they claim these are the
issues that are hot today that might
justify pushing that uh hand on the
clock further and further to 12 o'clock
and that's one of them is the new
variance of covid19 the other the slow
response of climate change a lot of
these scientists are worried very much
worried that the
politicians are not doing enough about
climate change and then there's all
these possible wars like ukraine taiwan
maybe coming up maybe countries like
iran and north korea you know these uh
mavericks out there that might drill
nukes or build them or whatever
so uh but despite this the bulletin is
optimistic about technological advances
to mitigate existential risk
which is kind of strange because uh if
um
seems like a contradiction because on
the one hand they're saying
the second hand is you know 100 seconds
away from doomsday
and then on the other they say oh but
we're optimistic
you would think we're optimistic we're
15 minutes away you know from doomsday
so you wonder about these scientists
anyways uh
fallout says
comment that someone made
says germany should be worried because
of ukrainian war probably coming up
russia provides them with most of their
heating energy yeah and i think
germany is worried and now you have a
government which is probably a little
closer to russia than the previous one
it sounds like that i don't know if
that's true
but there are a lot of relations between
germany and russia and so the question
is whether
germany is completely on board with uh
with the nato uh philosophy
you know they might act differently if
uh russia happens to attack ukraine
especially
russia does not attack so openly maybe
it's a little skirmish here and there
something that doesn't justify you know
uh
severing severing all
relations
so
we'll see what happens but yeah that's
something that's on on the books right
now all newspapers are dealing with this
subject okay it's an important issue i
think
okay uh
on the other side of the
world we have a similar situation china
obtaining tsmc fabs this is taiwan
semiconductor okay probably the biggest
prize that taiwan has in my opinion
and i expect important equipment would
be sabotaged uh or a spirited way of
china invaded yeah and i uh i kind of
agree with that you know they can
destroy it they can take it away where
they can take it away it's not so easy
to dismount all that equipment
okay uh or they'll take maybe the most
important equipment leave
some of the
uh you know
less technologically advanced equipment
behind who knows they might even destroy
the fab uh all that might happen it's
part of the war uh tactics or strategy
right and i'm sure some of that is being
thought out already in advance if china
invades taiwan someday okay um
but yeah
uh says i'm not sure that tsmc owns this
technology
the the issue there is that you can see
the fab there and uh
you know i i used to work in places like
that and
it's they own it because they own the
equipment
and they have the specs there to
manufacture chips so uh now once you
have the fab
that's more important in that sense than
design because design is done in the
offices
you know and uh they can design chips in
other places as well especially if they
have the blueprints uh right there for
tsmc no the important part is the fab
the the
the hardware okay that's important
because they have the equipment there so
yeah unless uh they decide to take it
away
remove it from taiwan in case of an
invasion
or they destroy it
i think it would fall in the hands of uh
mainland china so that's something you
got to think about if there is a war
which apparently is coming up a lot of
these countries have interests
ukraine
in taiwan in the middle east
so uh it might be a great year for war
it's about time we had a good war i mean
you know
right
okay if allah says about extinction he
says when you introduce the word if
into your propositions
then con conclusions uh that follows
becomes a prediction
if you you don't explain the mechanism i
didn't explain the mechanism i thought i
did but the guesswork based on if leads
you to imagine possible scenarios okay
basically bill says
this is what caused the extinction of
the dinosaurs okay this is the mechanism
okay so i did give you a mechanism now
project that to humans okay can man
elude the same mechanism
the same process right good question
man cannot elude right that's my
conclusion okay we can safely say that
someday man
humans become extinct
what is this reasoning i understand what
you're saying
why don't you do or not i mean uh he
says what is this reasoning and then he
contradicts himself saying i i
understand what you're saying but then
you know does he understand or doesn't
he
i have no idea
you know uh and again uh the the uh
argument is very simple if uh
whatever happened to dinosaurs
just to mention one case you know we can
go with the archosaurs or
the uh amphibians carboniferous whatever
uh we can go with any era okay any hepa
and uh we say well what happened to them
well this is what happened to them okay
whatever it did let's say we figured it
out now we take that cookie cutter right
and we apply it to man and we find out
through reasoning that we can't do about
anything about that same mechanism that
killed you know these animals in the
past
well then
you know we have a mechanism of
extinction
and again it's got nothing to do with uh
with the future with prediction it's got
to do with the fact that
if we cannot elude that mechanism it's a
done deal okay again i give the example
of buffalo's
running over a cliff or someone stepping
over a cliff well you know as soon as he
takes that step i'm gonna say if you
take that step you're gonna fall down
over the cliff
it's not a it's not a question of
whether he's gonna hit the ground or not
if he takes that step he will fall okay
so it's a guaranteed thing
uh so if the
if the
premise is correct if we accept it if we
concede it
then we have to conclude that whatever
follows from that premise will happen
and so i don't know how else to explain
that uh it's not a prediction it's got
to do with mechanism okay and so when
people focus on the word prediction say
oh you're talking about the future and
you know they get lost now this is not
about talking about the future and about
uh you know the day that it's gonna
happen predictions and foretelling and
crystal balls none of that has to do
with mechanism if you cannot elude a
mechanism the conclusion follows from
you know from that reasoning
so i don't know what else
uh how else to say that okay uh
moving on here we have another fellow
that says bill why don't you i think
it's saying phil
bill why don't you open a dictionary
once and for all
okay i'll try i'll try to open the
dictionary i don't have too many of them
but yeah i i can think i can find one
techno and logie in other words
technology from the greek and he goes
over the etymology of the word
technology where it comes from and all
that stuff which is totally irrelevant
please don't do that anymore
directly nuts puts all these etymologies
where the words came from nobody cares
especially when none of the words in the
ordinary dictionary have
can be considered to be scientific
especially the key words okay so
if technology came out of your uh
ordinary dictionary irrelevant and again
we don't rely on authority we
defend our definitions so if we have an
irrational definition we don't care what
the etymology was or how it's been used
in the past
we censor we say something's wrong with
that definition we have to revise it
that's the way it works in science okay
we don't use irrational definition
simply because of authority and
tradition that's the issue
okay it says has its uh has its up has
is its object the application and use of
technical
okay and in broad sense that is to say
of everything okay it covers everything
including the word knowledge and science
etc yeah uh this is the problem
technology has nothing to do with
science or with knowledge okay and uh so
you know to to put everything in there
and say i got it from the dictionary
yeah you haven't said anything
uh that can be applied to a solution
practical problems to the optimization
etc etc etc okay now that's not a
definition of technology okay let's
let's put a rational one okay and it's
got to do with two words one is
invention and the other one is
innovation today these two words are
essentially treated as synonyms even by
the patent office okay
and so we have to distinguish innovation
from invention invention has to do with
objects with things with tangible things
and innovation has to do with ideas with
concepts okay and so
uh you know you can patent an innovation
at the patent office because again they
haven't defined exactly what they mean
by invention and innovation as far as
the patent office is concerned they're
synonyms and now we have to distinguish
those in physics because physics deals
only with tangible objects out there
with with uh
in everyday physics right uh with
especially if you go do an invention it
better be seeable and tangible okay and
so here it is uh let me put over here so
you can compare it okay innovation
implementation of ideas
introduction of new methods what is an
invention a new tangible
gadget okay so these two words are not
synonyms
uh invention has to do with objects
innovation has to do with concepts
invention has to do with a manufacturing
economy innovation with a service
economy a computer prog program is not
an invention even though the patent
office might accept it as an invention
it is not for the purposes of physics we
have to distinguish these two words okay
and uh so the
patent office you know they might accept
it and and consider them synonym but we
we don't okay
so when uh people equate invention with
innovation they're talking about
ordinary speech means that they simply
got it out of the dictionary and they
copied and pasted which is what this
file did he just copied and pasted he
didn't even analyze what he what he was
copying or pasting he just copy paste
my god
oh it says
why did the neanderthals uh have sex
with sapiens and not produced children
yet they are the the genius of the order
of the primates et cetera et cetera okay
uh he said that we all descend from the
same tree essentially right
and they did not have a human genome uh
no because they were not humans
okay
uh our gorillas the same as you know
they have a human genome and now the
gorillas do not have human genome okay
why in your opinion nothing came out
well again because uh they were so
different uh you know
if you have sex with a gorilla or with a
chimpanzee i don't think anything good
will come out of that
now nothing will come out in fact they
tried the human z and nothing came out
so why would something come out of
neanderthal with humans or with uh
for for example homo erectus and humans
why would something come out of there
okay you have to specify or find out why
but more importantly how would they meet
in the wild why would a human you know
go out there into neanderthal territory
and suddenly decide to have sex with the
with this other species
okay
uh try one day just take a lion and take
it over to
you know tiger territory or vice versa
and see if they uh
they all decide to share
uh their wives or whatever
and so do not tell me species because
there is also a proposal that
neanderthals were a subspecies of the
sapiens
so nothing certain how rational is it
for your science to say species well
yeah you have to
define the term species and there we try
to do that viable breeding okay that's
what
species is essentially okay so if uh you
can have um
viable children
offspring with uh
with with
someone
that someone is
part of your species
now
you know it means you have to have
something come out okay first of all but
if whatever comes out is a hybrid and
that hybrid is sterile
then they're not of the same species or
they're at the borderline of of you know
being the same species maybe
next time they have success maybe next
time they don't okay
but but yeah you need to define the word
species because that's what's what in
interbreeding has to do with you know
you're saying okay if they interbreed
will they have successful children
viable children if they do then they are
of the same species their genes
their their makeup is not so far apart
okay and the question is whether the
neanderthals and humans
were even similar after 500 000 years of
separation
or so you know i mean we don't know
exactly how how long they were separated
but uh more than separation you know the
neanderthals grew up
evolved
in arctic uh europe
and they came out of you know they came
out of the uh apparently right they came
out no they didn't migrate there uh the
guys who migrated there were if anything
their ancestors which were the ancestors
or the
uh heidelbergs which didn't migrate
there either because they came from the
homo erectus who migrated there maybe
anywhere between 800 000 and 1 million
years ago
so those were the parents of
neanderthals
and you know by the time we get to
uh the arctic which uh art this arctic
weather you know there was northern
europe
we're talking about maybe 40 000
i'd say even less 35 000 years ago
and so when we got there i don't think
there were any neanderthals that's one
issue the other issue is that if there
were any neanderthals still alive
you know they
they were nude
they invented no clothes
neanderthals had no clothes here we were
you know in this freezing cold we we
were
you know wrapped up
and so here you see this neanderthal
looking at you and you're looking at
them he sees you with all these clothes
he doesn't know what you are
what did you put on
so yeah this is
my take on that is neanderthals and
humans were so far apart
and they had no common language they had
probably no similar sense you know you
gotta
smell them okay
uh i'm sure each one marked their
territories i'm even saying that uh
you know if they they had again
different weapons uh somewhat different
cultures because the by that time the
neanderthals were sedentary whereas
the
humans are pro-magnets right they were
uh moving into their territory they were
nomadic
so there were a lot of differences for a
human to sleep with a female neanderthal
or vice versa
i don't think it ever happened
and uh here's another issue
says compare or make a similarity with
the results of calhoun's experiment with
a human species no why well he says
comparing eight mice against two humans
you know for example adam and eve
because in the case of uh calhoun's
experiments we had four pairs of mice
and they immediately
each one took their wives uh each one of
the male mice uh took
their wives and uh went out and
squatted some territory and started
having kids okay and here they're
talking about two humans like adam and
eve you know uh are we the same thing
we came out of adam and eve apparently
uh but it says given perfect living
conditions man adapts to the environment
and survive okay everything they need
but who gives us everything we need in
other words the mice had everything they
needed
they were protected from cats and other
predators okay they were inside this
place they couldn't get out okay and
they just multiplied in there that's
essentially the experiment and he's
saying uh that we gave him everything we
gave him food
we gave him water and we gave them you
know nesting material so they had
everything they needed in there they
didn't have to go out and look for it
and he's saying that humans
are not like that in other words
regular humans like in the cities where
pretty much can leave the city come back
in and do whatever we want okay so he
says how similar to mice are we well i
think we are very quite like mice uh
beginning
with the fact that we're part of the
mammal world both mice and humans okay
we all come from mammals and we all
belong to the mammal world okay it's
because of the way we have children
okay and uh and then he continued he
says is the calhoun experiment
comparable to planet earth well in a way
it is and for what he says next he says
the mice will surely have tried to
escape the earth is it a perfect cage
where humanity has no escape yeah i'm
saying that
the earth is a perfect cage we cannot
escape earth okay we will never
colonize another planet we'll never
leave this is it we we are born here we
die here so in that sense yeah we are
very much like these mice we're trapped
on earth that we're
we don't have the freedom to leave okay
we can run an experiment you know go to
the moon maybe go to mars and that's
about it uh you know lab experiment
that's that's fine but that's not
evacuating earth okay or or forming a
colony somewhere
and are we humans also an experiment
yeah in a way uh i think we're an
experiment of mother nature
okay so
you can look at it that way okay
uh
you know we're our own experiment we
we're experiment with ourselves okay we
we go out there and we do experiments
like go to the moon we go to mars maybe
tomorrow
and
we go and come back and then we stay
here i don't know of anyone who lives on
the moon or in mars yet
and i doubt there ever will be because
extinction will catch us with our pants
down
but uh insists he says hey what if we go
to the moon
i like this one it says
the conquest of space to be called more
property black sky
is one of the most interesting
challenges of humanity if we did not
waste time and money in developing
military technology that can
self-destruct us totally
eliminate us in an extinction of the
species i would already be on vacation
on luna hotel
with a view of the ceo tranquility and
our blue pearl in the background so i
guess there he is he thinks he's going
to be
on a hammock you know near the beach
the uh sea of tranquility and with the
earth in the background yeah sure
i think a lot of these people watch too
much star trek that's what it is they
they think uh we can go to the moon and
just live there you know
and they have this in the back of their
minds that you know this is possible
it's never going to happen
you know that that's all to keep your
attention and people say oh we're going
to go to mars we're going to build you
know our station there and we're going
to live there we're going to expand
through mars
it's never ever going to happen if
anything the best that will ever happen
is we send a few
astronauts to mars
could happen we i think we have a
technology to do this okay
send a few asterosomars maybe even put a
station at some point
and whether it will ever be inhabited
i doubt it because they would have to
supply it constantly with everything
from earth and each expedition will cost
millions
right now uh i think the earth doesn't
have enough
money in the treasury for all that
expense now if anything we go to mars
step on it come back and never go back
again just like we did with the moon
there's no reason to go to the moon
there's no reason to go to mars there's
no military reason to go to mars
i mean you can develop their technology
to go to mars that might help the
military yeah and that could happen but
going to mars and then staying in mars
because that's going to help us in some
way
uh in in a war here on earth
absolutely not uh people are thinking in
terms of what they watch on on in the
movies on tv you know they say oh we're
gonna be shooting these laser guns
uh maybe they've been playing too much
with these paint guns on weekends
my god
okay here we have falses
also with the moon she said the moon
landing i believe in space and science
and a globe earth but to me it's
abundantly clear that the u.s government
live lied about going it was a dirty
trick played for propaganda and to save
face against the russian program
some people don't believe that we went
to the moon
and i guess uh you know you can take
that on to anything else it's like if
you don't experience it yourself you
won't believe it so jfk never existed he
was never killed okay uh
uh
lincoln never happened napoleon never
happened
yeah because i wasn't there to touch
uh lincoln or napoleon you know or
caesar julius caesar so if i'm not there
then it never happened because you know
i wasn't there
so i have no experience no hands-on
experience with it and so i have no
hands-on experience with the moon so
that or with these people going to the
moon so it never happened either because
i wasn't there
and the nuclear bombs never happened
because i wasn't there and so on and
people think that existence
is a question of um
you know having uh
touching and seeing
so uh
the ball that uh they're playing soccer
with on the other side of the planet
right now doesn't exist for me because
i'm not there i haven't been able to
touch it or see it so it doesn't exist
that's their reasoning
and so yeah uh you start to wonder yeah
you have to take some things for granted
and that's that you know what we do is
what the ancients used to do also in
their cultures which is pass from one
generation to the other some of the
stories that their
folks passed on to them
and so they took a lot of these uh for
granted a lot of them were you know
mixed with mythology and so on
okay uh but today we've gotten a little
better on that also we got better at
lying but it's harder to lie with people
who have already some experience with
lying okay so
you know you cannot say well jfk never
happened and uh roosevelt never happened
and i don't know
lincoln never happened washington never
happened
you can't say that because you know
these things have been passed down from
generation to generation and what i'm
going to say these these people did not
exist simply because i never saw never
touched them okay and so here you know
uh this well maybe he didn't see
uh men go to the moon and i don't mean
to the tv i mean like he wasn't on the
moon to see them land there so
we're not supposed to believe that
humans went to the moon simply because
of this because i wasn't there
i mean what's the reasoning
and so uh here i can only provide a
couple of uh
off the top of my head by the way okay
because i think we did have the
technology to go to the moon without any
problem okay
and these are other uh questions he
might ask himself
the soviets did not question the moon
landings you would think that if the
soviets uh
didn't believe it happened
they would have said something said well
no you guys said you went to the moon
but it really didn't happen
and then the question is
also goes in reverse the americans could
have said well gagarin and
you know the dog
those were all hoaxes russians never
went up there
they could have said that right because
uh you know even the united states
accepts today that garden was uh
the first man to orbit the earth
and so and to rescue about the first
woman and so
you know why would they concede such a
thing it would have been much easier for
the united states to say well now that
didn't happen the russians are lying
i mean we got to take in both directions
okay and the same with uh the russians
the russians should have questioned the
moon landings and say well that never
happened
and that's not the case the russians
accept that the moon landings did happen
they were worried because you know all
this technology was developed
in great measure that was one of the
reasons they were worried so no they
the russians accept that
the americans went to the to the moon
and therefore this notion that you know
that um
it was just a dirty trick for propaganda
you know i don't think the russians
bought it
the propaganda they they knew it was
real
and then uh you have so many missions i
mean you're talking about at least 60
years since the 60s okay
and you're saying they're all fake
nobody saw anything you you can go to
you know the
uh
space
uh platform there
in florida and watch the rockets go out
okay and yeah you can film them
you know take your camera take your
telescope and you can watch it go out
into outer space
so
we haven't gone into space we haven't
put satellites out there why wouldn't we
go to the moon if we have the ability to
go into orbit
okay so these are other things you gotta
ask yourself
and then chinese recently you know they
started the uh their um
space uh program
relatively recently but you know they
don't go to space either
again you know you you gotta go deeper
you can't just pull one thing out of
nowhere and say well i don't think they
went to space because it was just for
propaganda you know that argument can
easily be turned around okay and thrown
against you so
you know all i can tell you is yeah we
we did go to space yeah to to the moon
uh there was no purpose to go to the
moon in the first place other than to
develop technology but once we went to
the moon uh or at least the americans
went to the moon they found no for for
the reason to go to the moon why would
they go to the moon to do what
plant potatoes
i mean you know you know what it costs
to send someone out there just insurance
costs and then you know when you bring
them back uh you send another crew and
you gotta keep feeding them i mean
assuming you create a uh
a
station on the moon right a permanent
one
you gotta keep feeding them and taking
air and water and all this stuff up
there what for
what are they going to do out there on
the moon
that they can't do like for example with
a skylab an orbiting lab which is much
closer by
you know so again there's no reason to
go to the moon that's why we haven't
gone to the moon again because what are
we going to go there for just to pull
some rocks see the dark side of the moon
and say oh it looks pretty take a
snapshot and bring
the picture back
no there it will never go to the moon
again for any real reason maybe just uh
just to develop technology that's it
but the moon itself or mars itself
there's no purpose
none whatsoever so it'll never happen
because again there's no reason to go
there other than to say we made it once
we touched base came back we did it
let's celebrate pull out the champagne
bottles and that's it that's where it
dies
it won't go beyond that
okay uh fellow says morals the god of
doom has spread his spirit of impending
doom
who drives mortals to their deadly fate
and uh morris has nothing but
pessimistic view for humanity
and there's uh morris at the bottom
there
he's the greek god of uh faint of uh
doom
uh yeah uh again uh people think that
when i'm uh doing uh all these
predictions as they call them
it's it's not predictions i'm talking
about mechanisms and they focus on uh
prediction they they think i'm an
astrologer or something you know with my
crystal ball and saying oh
on the first of july of the year 2029
we're going to become extinct
now that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying there's a mechanism we cannot
avoid and it's the mechanism that causes
all mass extinctions
and that's a little different than
saying i predict
you know this is not nostradamus
nostradamus okay uh he's uh
he just got it on top of his head and
i'm not doing that i'm saying look i've
got a mechanism that is foolproof you
can't beat it no matter what you do you
can't beat this mechanism the mechanism
is the collapse of the global economy we
can't do anything about it no matter
what we do and it comes to
the subject uh it's coming up in a
couple more of your
comments that people made here's the
first one paul says bill economists are
saying that the economy is doing really
good right now almost too good this is
why the supply chains can't keep up with
demand you know uh deliveries
uh
are falling behind partly because some
people don't want to work
and i guess they're not paying enough to
get people to go to work and so
deliveries are falling behind and demand
is uh
is i guess overpowering supply right i
have noticed from a personal aspect that
the big box stores and other stores
chain stores are very much busy all the
time i don't know what to think of this
all i can tell you is that first of all
we're moving
you got to look at the big picture macro
economics okay and what i'm saying not
micro you're talking about
microeconomics and i'm saying
macroeconomics trumps
uh microeconomics
um all these people
who are
what is it
i call them narco uh
uh what is it
uh
they're called the narco capitals i call
them narco caps okay these folks are
typically uh
micro economic economists they don't
think about the macro
world okay and what i'm saying is macro
trumps micro in other words you can't
develop yourself
small guy
in a in a world that doesn't develop
itself so if the world is shutting down
because macroeconomics is falling apart
it doesn't matter if a company here and
another one there does well okay
so
i i overrule microeconomics with
macroeconomics what's happening to
macroeconomics we're moving into the
service world
services is unemployment that's what it
is another word for unemployment when
you do services all you're doing is
passing money around
until that money goes into building
something
or something that's tangible
uh could be food could be a building
could be a car
until that translates into something
like that there is no growth all you
have is been
pushing money around i give you money
because you signed a contract the other
guy
uh gives money to the other fellow
because he's uh in the insurance
business he insured the operation uh the
other guy puts it in the bank and the
bank controls the money and helps uh
people you know manage their accounts
what is all that
nothing
are we doing passing money around what
does a programmer do nothing all he does
is play around with the computer change
some programs there and for doing that
he gets money what did he do nothing he
created an abstraction
until all that turns into something
solid we have no growth growth has to do
only with
tangible things
physics real physics not with philosophy
and when uh like i said when you're up
there with god and looking down at the
planet what do you see well what is
growth growth is real growth growth of
that which you can see
maybe touch
right
you see roads buildings you know you see
um
fields of corn
houses
cars
ships airplanes whatever
you have growth
but we can't see the promises we can't
see what the insurance company
promised you or the contract or whatever
all that is fake
and so when you move into the service
world
and abandoning the manufacturing the
tangible
part of our economy
you go into unemployment and so that's
one issue uh for this fall the other
issue is that um
you know i don't i don't know how many
countries are doing well
a lot of countries are not doing well
and i think
just like within a country you get the
rich getting richer and the poor getting
poorer that's a trend that's been going
on for quite a while it happens also on
a worldwide scale where you have the
rich countries getting richer and the
poor countries getting poorer with
respect to them
that's also happening and the question
is how far can can the rich become rich
and the poor become poor when the rich
depend on the poor
so keep all this in mind the macro is
important don't look at oh i saw the
store sell a lot of stuff and the
numbers are going up as i showed you
just now uh
with the graph what is it 2020
they were expecting a big rise and they
didn't expect this cobit thing to come
around so the predictions were wrong and
they had really negative growth during
2020.
compared to that 2021
was
you know positive why because they went
down so low that any improvement over
that previous year was you know positive
so they had like five percent growth but
was that real growth no that was growth
with respect to the previous year
i don't think we got back to 2019 yet
so keep that in mind there's a lot of
stuff going on uh you can't treat that
so
superficially okay you gotta look at it
in more detail
okay and final issue if i says our main
reason for extinction stupidity
[Laughter]
we have screwed our culture up to the
point that some purpose
fully try to degrade it further along
with morality others hate our
traditional culture and what it
eliminated which will destroy everything
well again people
get into politics and that's what they
want to talk about here we try to talk
about
physics meaning mechanisms meaning
theories meaning
explanations okay we have to explain a
mechanism and the extinction theory has
to do with the mechanism
uh the causes of extinction of man
and so that's got very little to do with
the rich taking advantage of the poor
that's always happened there ask marx
karl marx would have told you would have
given you a sermon on that
and uh you know
that's always happened where the rich
took advantage of the poor
you know one human taking advantage of
another that's always happened
uh
that's not the issue the issue is can we
do anything about extinction can the
rich
with all their power that all their
might all their money can they do
anything about extinction my answer is
no
okay so let's move on here let's go with
the neutron okay
and uh the other day we started with
israel his name is uh peter peregrinis
what did he come up with well he came up
with positive and negative
i'm sorry not positive he came up with
north and south pole he was the first
guy to propose as far as i know i don't
know if any other
of any uh
some of anyone's before peregrines that
came up with this north and south if you
do please let me know i really like to
know but as far as i know this is the
first of all that talks about north and
south pole of a magnet
and in in a letter he wrote to a friend
which has turned it has been turned into
a book
uh he just says look
there's the north and the south pole one
point to the north pole the other one to
the south pole okay and he showed his
friend in the letter he explained to him
how to discover which one's the north
pole which one's the south pole
did he explain
how a magnet works
absolutely not okay
and uh so a couple centuries later a few
more than that more than a couple okay
we have this one his name is ben
franklin and he came up with
a notion that we used still today and
that's the negative and positive
actually he
liked to talk more about the plus and
minus
his theory was essentially that there
was a
electricity with some kind of fluid and
either you had it or you didn't and so
it was like a plus when you had it and a
minus when you didn't so uh
this is where the notion of positive and
negative originated okay
and yeah these uh fellows just uh
gave labels to something they they did
not understand
and it turns out that here we are
hundreds of years later from paraguayans
and at least a couple hundred from ben
franklin
and they still don't know the
mathematicians still haven't figured out
what north and south pole mean or
positive and negative mean
okay
and so here we are positive and negative
north and south pole what are we
referring to well specifically in the
case of what we're going to deal with
today the word charge and we have
positive and negative charge
what the in the world is positive charge
negative charge anybody have any idea
i mean look it up in your
quickly you know in your uh physics
textbook maybe maybe you can enlighten
me today okay
okay so uh what happened well we had
only positive and negative for quite a
while at least 100 years i would say
and um
joseph thompson okay english fell
he uh eventually zeroed in there were
many people working on this by the way
they exchanged ideas he finally came up
with a notion that uh there was
something called an electron and this
was
assigned
the so-called negative charge okay so
the electron now was the negative fella
okay
and a few years later
uh almost 20 years
brother ford you ran his uh back
scattering experiment
and he
zeroed in on this notion of the proton
that was given the prop positive charge
did any of these two fellows know what
negative and positive charge
means in physical terms
the answer is
no
okay
neither one even to this day have no
idea what negative and positive charge
mean in physical terms these are
mathematical terms
so we come to the
neutron
which has no charge at all
so what we need to figure out today
among other things is
what is this absence of charge that
the neutron has or doesn't have i don't
i don't know
which way you want to uh phrase it you
know the neutron doesn't have charge
what is it that it doesn't have
it's like you know i have 10 cents in a
dime in my pocket right
so if i don't have it well i have the
absence of a dime but i you know we know
what a dime is because when i do have it
i can say this is a diamond i show you a
dime right
uh can we do that with charge can i say
well
i have the absence of charge okay what
is it when you do
half charge
uh what are you gonna show me okay so
uh charge is not a thing
but as we've seen in the last couple
lectures you know these people are
moving
charges
so when you talk about moving charges
you know if i say well i'm going to move
this little ball right
people say okay i understood that you're
moving the ball you're moving it from in
my case uh what left to right okay so
i'm moving the ball from left to right
i can say that because you know i have
something for you to see and touch
you know
but uh when you say charge
what is it that you're moving from left
to right how did charge move from left
to right
and how about no charge
absence of charge what is it you're
moving from left to right
it gets scary after a while okay because
you don't know what these people are
moving
okay so what was this how did we come up
with this notion of the neutron which is
a so-called particle that has no charge
okay so it's different than the proton
different than the electron what is it
like okay that's what we're gonna try to
reach here okay well this fella his name
is james chadwick and uh 1932 he
did a couple of experiments in published
a paper in which he said i discovered
the neutron what is the neutron well
it's kind of like the proton
in size and mass etc
but
unlike the proton it has no charge and
it's inside the nucleus of the atom
okay most atoms
the only one that doesn't have one is
the hydrogen atom unless it's a
deuterium or uh tritium okay
okay so uh he comes up with this neutron
and um
how did he come up with this well they
had until then the idea that
uh
there was something inside the helium
atom that didn't make sense
because it turns out that the helium
atom
had two charges two positive charges two
negative charges but a helium so-called
weighed
not like two hydrogen atoms but like
four of them
okay
so here's the uh rundown of how uh they
came up with this notion of the neutron
the helium atomic number was two but the
mass number was four
okay so helium had two charges like two
hydrogen atoms but it weighed like four
hydrogen atoms okay this was the problem
so they had to figure out what was going
on how come it only had two charges if
it weighed you know a lot more twice as
much as what it should have weighed
and so uh what uh chadwick did he
bombarded beryllium with particles okay
with alpha particles and he concluded
that the radiation ejected from
beryllium was a neutral particle having
approximately the mass of the proton
okay that's that's how this all went
until then they thought it was photons
neutral photons
uncharged photons that were uh
causing this
and he said no when he did his
experiment he says no
a photon cannot move you know uh the
particles that we're removing from the
atom the beryllium atoms that he was
bombarding them with he said no it's got
to be something massive
and he figured out that no there's some
other particle in there that we missed
and they call that particle the neutron
okay
again a lot of this was math
they never saw a neutron
they just said something's happening in
there these are the calculations from
those calculations they inferred
that there's got to be another particle
and because of the situation they said
well this particle weighs as much as a
proton or
just about
but it doesn't have charge and that's
the only way we can explain
the helium atom
okay so this was the the reason this is
how they came up with the neutron okay
okay so but it turns out that like i
told said the other day um
the proton is not the only particle that
is positive okay
there's a couple more and i covered them
the other day i'm just go quickly here
uh protons made of three quarks and it's
a
so-called
positive uh charge the positively
charged particle okay but then you have
also the positron uh discovered by
anderson okay
um
and
it's that little trace there because the
positron you know it's not like we have
a particle and say here's the particle
you know i can't show you a positron
it's uh essentially has i guess the size
of an electron which is no size point
particle okay
uh the only difference is that positron
has a p plus it's a an electron is
positive that's essentially what the
positron amounts to
and all they said is it's that trace
there okay that's how he
anderson proved it carl anderson and got
a nobel prize for that okay so all we
know about the positron it's a trace
they call it a particle but it's a trace
that's all we have
okay and then uh
we've talked about the whole the fact
that you know you have this hole created
when an electron leaves its
uh
atom so it leaves a hole behind and you
know a
void
and so as the electrons move to one dir
in one direction the holes
you can conceptualize holes moving the
opposite direction
and here you have a picture of that okay
essentially you can see the electrons
moving in one direction
and the holes positive ones because the
electron is negative the holes are
moving in the opposite direction used
significantly or quite a bit in
semiconductor processing i dealt a lot
with this and there you see the analogy
down at the bottom you move the little
16 squares one of them to the side which
you leave behind as a whole so instead
of looking at the white
uh boxes you look at the holes they
leave behind and that's more or less the
idea of the hole
okay so what's the issue the issue is
that
these people are talking about
positive particles
aside from the proton we have the proton
the positron and the holes at least
maybe they'll find some more out there
and there are yeah for sure but those
are the main ones but it turns out that
we also have many
uncharged particles not only the neutron
okay here it is okay
neutrons uncharged but we also have
neutrinos photons the photon
is uncharged
and you say why isn't it charged why
can't
you know
in other words
you heard maybe that gravity pulls on
light meaning it bends
the beam
could that be charged i'm sure the
electrical universe the electric
universe people they would probably
agree that if
all this is electrical and gravity is
electrical
then uh if it's true that a beam is
deflected by gravity
uh
then it's because you know it's got it
has the opposite charge to gravity
right we could conceptualize that
photons have charged but right now they
say photons have no charge neither do
gluons the little particles that keep
the
quartz from flying away you know inside
the proton and the neutron okay so the
gluons all those are also uncharged so
the pions the chaons the z bosons the
higgs discovered a few years ago right
they say
uh the higgs boson
bozos those that aren't charged so are
the gravitons
okay
none of these are charged in other words
they're not electrical particles
according to quantum mechanics
but on the other hand neutrons are
in other words they're uncharged but
well we'll get to that in a second here
they're they're uncharged but they are
charged
and uh
let's find out how they figure out that
the electron is charged first and what
does charge mean in mathematics okay
mathematics or mathematics as i call it
okay they have this uh robert milligan
and he came up with an experiment to
determine what the charge on an electron
is it's known as the oil drop experiment
1909
and what he did he drip let some oil
drip through an orifice there and then
was able to suspend it in the air okay
and so he essentially you know with a he
had an electric field from the top
pulling from the top on the particle and
at the same time it had to fight against
gravity
so all he had to do was figure out uh
calculate you know the
the ratio there between gravity and the
electrical field and he was able to
determine the charging on an electron
and
today we use the charge on an electron
and also on the positron by the way just
opposite signs uh what is it 1.6 times
10 to the minus 19 coulombs okay
okay
so um
how do they calculate or how do they
determine that the proton and the
neutron
have one has charge and the other one
doesn't have charge how do they
determine that okay and here you have
again mathematics that's all it is okay
what they do is uh they take uh the
proton which they eventually zeroed in
and they said um it's got two up quarks
and one down
quark that's what the proton is made of
whereas the neutron is made of two down
quarks and one up quark and so what they
did is they gave these quarks
um
charges
but they gave them fractions of charges
so they took like the up quarks there
you know and they have two thirds uh
charge
plus two-thirds charge minus one-third
charge well that's four-thirds minus one
third gives you three thirds meaning one
and in case of the neutrons it took uh
the plus two thirds of the up quark and
they subtracted two one thirds
uh of the down quarks and that gave them
zero
so it's a mathematical calculation baby
stuff really kindergarten stuff and they
say that's what the pro why the proton
has charge
okay and why the
neutron does
not and
the question is how do you do that with
the electron
because the electron is just given
one uh
one charge right 1.6 times 10 to the
minus 19 coulomb that's the charge on
the electron but the electron is not
made of simpler parts that's the
official version it's a point particle
it's a
zero dimensional
if you're going to go with a notion of
point particle okay
and so
how did they you know how do they do
this math with the electron
okay so this is the issue uh they did it
for the proton and the neutron they get
nobel prizes for this stuff they say oh
you figured it out one third one third
one third we did it with quarks okay so
okay
so this is how again what i want you to
know is that it's all math it has
nothing to do with them going to the lab
and proving or seeing you know observing
with the eyes
uh what really occurred there has
nothing at all to do with that they just
took the proton and said why does this
one have positive charge where does that
the neutron have no charge they say oh i
know we divided in three two up quarks
one down quark one two down quarks one
up quark we got it made we can explain
charge
and how can you explain charge if you
don't know what charge is what do you
mean by charge is it a physical object
what is it that the neutron doesn't have
once you did all that calculation end up
with zero charge what is it that it
lacks
what is it the proton has
just a number coulombs
is that what a charge is
okay uh so here's what the proton looks
like today okay because of that okay
it's got these three quarks okay
and
they're
uh prevented from leaving that globe
that
sphere
by the
springs
they're all bound by springs those
springs are known as gluons which is
allegedly a particle that goes back and
forth between these three quarks okay
two ups and one down
and so the question is you know
what are those
springs why do they put springs in there
because you don't find them in the
standard model if i go to a standard
model and this is glue on and i see a
spring i say okay
very straightforward you know the glue
one looks like a spring and it's binding
to two quarks i understand that we all
understand that right
very simple
but you go to the standard model you
don't see any springs no glue on springs
there shows up as a ball
supposedly uh
quarks sends
uh glue onto the other quark and they
just trade quarks uh trade gluons back
and forth
how does that keep them together
how does sending little particles
keep
two uh
quarks together
and it turns out that these particles go
in a spiral
that's why they ended up with this
spring
because they they put the
what you're staring at when you look at
a spring glue on spring which you're
really looking at according to them
the mathematicians is the spiraling of a
particle so that's a trace that you're
seeing there
but they always put the spring
and people say well i understand what's
happening there the
quarks don't fly away because they're
bound by the spring no no what you're
seeing there is the trace of a gluon in
a spiral manner going from
one quark to another quark
that doesn't explain why the quarks
don't fly away
and the same with a neutron that's a
proton here's the neutron okay
so you can see them side by side one has
two ups and one down the other one has
two downs and one
up great
and both of them have these gluon
springs
which are not springs which are the
motion the spiraling motion okay of um
particles known as gluons
but you know what we're concerned about
because there's this other issue here
and it's this here you see them we want
to know what those spheres are that keep
that they always draw and that keeps you
know these um
quarks from flying away here are the
quarks they don't fly away okay
and why don't they well they say because
this uh gluon spring holds them together
which is not a gluon spring that's a
first problem but the second problem is
even if you remove the gluon springs
completely the question is what is that
sphere
in which the quarks are trapped and so
let's remove all that stuff let's remove
the gluon springs let's remove the
quarks and now we have just the spheres
what are those spheres what a material
are they made on what is that why do
they put them in there
this is the question you have to ask
okay because they put them in by hand
but uh just to show that the uh proton
and the neutron are spherical particles
but what are we staring at what what is
this uh this sphere
and so yeah that's all put in by hand we
have no idea what they're talking about
when they put them in there they never
identify that they just put the gluons
together with the quarks and this
unidentified sphere
because the whole thing is the proton
the whole thing is the neutron
it's the three quarks the gluons and the
sphere what is the sphere why did they
put it in there why don't they get rid
of the sphere completely and just put
the gluons and protons say well this is
what a neutron the gluons in quarks and
this is what a proton or a neutron look
like it looks like two balls uh tied by
springs
three three balls tied by spring no
that's not what they do they put that
sphere in there to make it look pretty
okay and it's misleading because people
say well i understand that you know they
can't leave
the
quarks because they're bound by the
sphere
so it's misleading because they never
identify what that sphere is
okay
here we have uh
one of the things that keeps them busy
at night which is this neutron beta
decay also there's a proton that turns
into a neutron but here we're going to
look at the neutron turning into a
proton and what it is is that
neutrons
have the ability to turn into a proton
plus an electron and an
anti-neutrino okay and so uh if you put
those together uh it matches a neutron
and the reason for that is
again
we're doing math we're not doing physics
here we're doing math they're saying
look if you take the neutron it weighs
or has the mass right
of all these three particles when you
put them together
and so it's just a
an accounting procedure they say look
neutron weighs a little more than the
proton well how much more well it weighs
like a proton an electron and an antino
neutrino okay that's what they're saying
and uh so is a neutron really neutral i
mean does it have no charge whatsoever
you can say that it's a blend of
positive and negative charge
that's what a neutral
neutron is allegedly in other words it's
got a blend
a mixture of positive and negative
charge that cancel out one has a
positive charge the other one has a
negative charge you take the positive
value which is a positive x minus
uh x what does it give you zero
so it's so this is an accounting
procedure it's got nothing to do with
reality it's got to do with this is the
way they calculated
you know how a neutron
doing its beta decay turns into a proton
and an electron something was left over
and they said we'll call that the
anti-neutrino
it's all accounting math that's all it
is nothing related to physics they have
no idea what any of these particles
look like or whether they even exist
okay they have no idea whatsoever
they've never seen one of these
particles they haven't seen a
hydrogen atom
which
you know when you look at it it's
it's a solar system according to them
and you have a very tiny proton in the
center
and this electron is miles away
okay it's uh
if you were to do an analogy you know
you would say uh maybe it's like
being uh the center of a football field
and this and the electron is uh
you know
on the outer
perimeter of the stadium you have a
little dot in the center and the
electron would be out there
and so if that's the atom and we can't
see that certainly we can't see the
little dot in the center called the
proton or the neutron right which are
approximately the same size according to
them
and for sure we have never seen an
electron
not to mention an anti-neutrino okay so
none of this has anything to do anything
to do with uh physics or with them
actually
seeing in the lab observing the word
observe right uh any of these particles
they've never seen one of these
particles okay
so all it is is math and that's what
beta decay is essentially it's a an
accounting procedure and that's how they
discover new particles like quarks and
anti-neutrinos
okay what's the rope model okay
and uh so to so that you have something
to compare it against okay here's our
neutron
okay
and give it a second here you'll see
what happens
all ropes in the universe
supposedly crisscross somewhere in space
here there and everywhere okay so we
should have many cross points for ropes
across the universe all atoms are
physically interconnected
so not only is an atom connected to
another atom and those atoms are made
the proton of threads
coming from every rope in the universe
and the
electrons made of uh threads that curve
around and encapsulate the proton but
then those ropes themselves have to
crisscross somewhere in space somewhere
and what we're saying is that's what the
neutron is and there i drew around it
approximately the same size as what the
atom is the hydrogen atom that's why the
neutron weighs approximately the same
uh as the hydrogen atom so i'm saying
that neutron is simply
a uh different uh
configuration of these same ropes okay
and here we're gonna see them side by
side here's the proton and
and the neutron essentially what we're
seeing is the atom against the neutron
okay
there you see the proton in the neutron
are they built
well in the case of the proton it's made
of all these threads coming from every
rope in the universe and right at the
center there okay you see the
proton star encapsulated by the
uh
the membrane the electron membrane in
the case of the neutron it's only just
the ropes and i drew the
approximately size of you know the
perimeter of the atom so that you can
get an idea why the neutron has
approximately the same mass as the
hydrogen atom or as the proton okay so
this is the
proposal okay
and
in the case of beta decay uh assuming it
happens because we cannot
uh put our hand in the fire for the beta
decay but here's we're going to show you
beta decay
okay and what you're seeing here
is that the proton
opens up and
turns into the ropes
because the electron membrane
essentially comes into the atom and
comes out of the atom goes back and
forth every 15 or so minutes which is
what they say happens spontaneously with
free neutrons out there okay and so here
you have it you have essentially you
know the
proton star
and the electron membrane that
essentially comes out the thread one of
the threads comes out okay
and
forms this
peripheral um
membrane that encapsulates the proton
okay so we have an explanation under the
um rope model
of how
beta decay could be occurring assuming
it happens because again we're relying
on what these people say happens in the
lab what they observed that a neutron
spontaneously turns into a proton and an
electron well there we have it the
electron is that membrane around
that encapsulates the proton star
okay so this is the notion we
make it with the same material that
makes up the atom so if beta decay
happens
we say we have a
an answer to that question as well okay
okay let's go with our conclusions
and here we have them
i hope ah
there you go
all the way to the bottom let me get
them up there
um
quantum mechanics has no idea what a
neutron looks like
so we can't really
give you a picture
of the neutron because they have no idea
all it is is math no physics okay hume
has no idea what charge is in physical
terms they have no idea what no charge
means in other words uh what a neutron
no charge
particle is what it looks like what
would it be different from proton okay
just a mathematical calculation that's
all it is no physical object called
charge and charge is a mathematical
concept okay so all they did was put a
value there
okay they're saying one has this value
and the other one doesn't
what is it that it has we have no idea
okay
so neutron uh equal no charge uh there's
no physical meaning
to it in quantum mechanics today in
mathematical physics so again are they
doing physics or are they doing math
that's the question you should ask
yourself and the neutron charge is
constructed with plus and minuses in
other words the neutron the absence of
charge
the no charge is is simply a mixture of
proton with electron
and they don't know what positive or
negative is but when you put them
together you get no charge meaning you
get
negative x plus x that gives you zero
that's that's all they're saying it's a
mathematical calculation we have no idea
what it means physically under the rope
model we're saying yeah what we have is
the
uh
electron
membrane can fold in and continue as
ropes and then at the same time he can
open up and form the atom
and so he can do this back and forth
just roll and unroll one of the threads
going in
uh so it continues as a rope and then
comes back out
okay so it can do that 50 every 15
minutes according to the beta decay
process they say it occurs
in free
neutrons that are not part of an atom
and so we have an explanation if that is
what occurs okay so
no math it's physics okay we have a
picture a movie of what's happening
and um
uh yeah qm neutron the quantum
neutron is contingent on the planetary
atom very important point because what
is helium well helium supposedly has two
protons two neutrons
and two electrons
but what is that
it's the little electron moving around
okay
orbiting
the this nucleus made of two protons two
neutrons
so the math is there they're saying you
have
the the helium atom looks like four
hydrogen atoms in fact with that they
can explain how the sun works you know
at the center of the sun uh you have
four hydrogen atoms fused into
one helium atom and what's released is
so-called word called energy great
but uh but then the question is you have
two protons two neutrons and the two
electrons are orbiting
so the neutron notion the notion of the
neutron is
contingent based on
the uh
planetary model of the atom
if the planetary model is no good or you
don't accept it because it's you can't
explain how the electron bead does not
fly out of the atom
then all bets are off then we have no
neutron okay
and finally if neutron decays to proton
and electron the rope model can simulate
this phenomenon with flying colors okay
so uh we do have a physical proposal for
how the neutron works
what it is what it looks like
quantum has none of those it cannot
explain except in mathematical terms
they cannot explain in physical
terms
okay
let's go on with the questions the
comments that people made since last
time
paul says
what happened here
i don't know why i can't see it
why can't i see this
give me a second here i don't know what
happened
i put this thing up there and i can't
see it
why can't i see it
okay i guess i'll have to go with the
second one
yeah there it is i don't know why they
can't see the first one
something happened to that so one of the
questions i'll have to
you'll have to take a rain check next
time have to do with calculating mass
okay
i don't know why i can't see it
give me a second here let me get it out
of the way
okay uh faucets peer review part of the
scientific method
is it
subjects uh scholarly work and research
to the scrutiny of other experts in the
same subjects
subject scholarly work and research to
the scrutiny of other experts in the
same field to check its validity and
evaluate its suitability for publication
uh-huh okay scientific method attempts
to minimize the influence of bias or
prejudice in the experimenter
okay that's assuming experiment have
anything to do with science right we can
do all kinds of experiments it doesn't
mean we understood anything you know a
famous
experiment we let go of the pencil
okay we did the experiment we do it
again to check gravity right again two
icy fell down we did a repeatable
scientific experiment now the because i
did an experiment does that mean
i understand what caused gravity
so yeah you can do a lot of experiments
experiments is not a part of science
explaining the experiment that's the
part of science that's the part where
science vibrates but to do an experiment
say i did an experiment
okay what did you do i jumped into the
pool and i did it 10 times what did you
learn well i didn't learn much but i did
it i did the experiment so i'm a
scientist now doing experiments is not
science it's explaining experiments that
is science explaining the mechanisms but
uh here we have um
give me a second here
uh
this is the answer to the peer review
okay
who gave them the authority who gave uh
these
uh monks you know the authority to serve
as
judges over you
did you give them the authority how do
you know they know
from whom do they learn i mean uh here
we have these uh so-called monks
and they come up and they say uh there's
something called a zero dimensional
singularity which
uh
swings stars around itself
and then we have a four-dimensional
space time which we cannot imagine which
is causing which is the cause
the reason you know that the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system or
spacetime
and so
apparently they don't know much and
you're gonna
give them the authority to rule over you
to
peer review your paper
i don't think so
will you submit your paper to a review
by
these individuals who believe in these
kinds of things will you submit your
paper to review by an individual who
believes that a particle can be in two
places at once
sounds peer review is merely a way to
preserve the status quo
so no we don't we don't use a peer
review in science uh
what we do is uh
we criticize yeah you can say that's
peer review but if the person you know
presents his case presents the objects
and a theory
uh
it should be published as long as he
follows the scientific method and that
should be straightforward um
you know you can check to see if
he followed the scientific method that's
about as far as peer review should go
but the merits
of the theory you know is a question of
belief
and so
you know once the guy follows a
scientific method uh
there's nothing wrong with a theory okay
the theory
whether you believe it or not which is
what peer review is all about what
you're going to allow to be published
out there that's uh that's called
censorship
that's not called a peer review okay and
not called science for sure
okay uh another file says or ass
says if the rope forks at the atom one
thread for the electron one for the
protons then shouldn't they both weigh
the same in other words the protons
should weigh the same as the electron
right because they're all made of same
threads
right or have the same mass
well
the issue here is that um
we're comparing apples and oranges we're
comparing quantum mechanics against the
rope model
and under the quantum mechanics when
they talk about the
at the
electron weighing 1800 times
less
than the proton what they're talking
about a little dot that allegedly you
know orbits
the nucleus
and so they say well this one weighs
less than that one
under the rope model what they're
talking about is a little point
on the edge of the of the membrane that
encapsulates the proton
okay so so that's what we're talking
about so
we're not talking about the whole
membrane
okay
and so you got to keep that in mind but
um here's a part of the answer to that
what this fellow raises um
and that's that how they calculate the
mass of the electron
and
again you know
it's not like they really go out there
and weigh the electron put it on a scale
or anything like that this is one of the
methods that they use
uh this came out of the max planck
institute they blast off carbon six
electrons okay and they induce the c12
you know a single electron to race
around a circuit
okay so they have this c12 going around
carbon right
they calculate the length of the circuit
okay they count how many times the c12
goes around
okay
they estimate the c12 speed
right and the electron speed a spin
precesses uh in this magnetic field
and uh
then they do a calculation the
revolution frequency of c12 and electron
spin precession are in an exact ratio of
one to another
that's the way they calculate it okay
again it's a calculation
based on the notion that they're talking
about a the planetary model of the atom
okay and so people don't always
understand that that's the case
okay what we're talking about here is
the planetary model which later on they
deny at the end of their uh lecture they
say oh by the way that uh atom that we
talked about for the last two hours
that's not our atom
so they they talk about the electron
bead right you're going to pull six of
them out of the carbon atom they're
going to run the
carbon atom around
then they're going to look at spin which
is not spin by the way
another
topic
and then they say there's a ratio there
and based on that they do a calculation
they say this is the
electron spin
electron mass but what do they base it
on they base it on the planetary model
of the atom they're assuming the
electron is a bead to begin with that's
going around
okay so they don't know what they're
doing but the calculation is what they
are concerned about and they say well
the electron in order to make this work
the electron would have to weigh so much
okay so that's how they calculate this
but they've never seen oh look they
don't even know what an electron looks
like
okay so unless you understand that to
begin with that they're working off of
the planetary model of the atom which
has no rationality whatsoever because
you cannot explain why the electron b
does not fly away or fall into the
nucleus what's keeping it bound to the
nucleus unless you can answer that you
don't have an atom to begin with and the
the
assumption under which they do all these
experiments is already
uh
baseless it's it's irrational
you have to understand that part first
okay you got to go deeper before you
just you know gawk at the experiments
that these people do and say oh man you
guys are so smart now they're not so
smart because
before you do
an experiment you got to do a design of
experiment these people have not done
any design of experiment because if they
put it on the board whatever they put on
the board is nonsense they're gonna put
a planetary model there okay that's
where the whole thing fails
okay we have a flat earther he came over
and he says uh just like the globe earth
all mathematical physics nothing but the
globe can be practically demonstrated
nothing about i mean nothing about the
globe can be
demonstrated all it has is
interpretations of uh
non-tangible visible
phenomena you know uh lumiere's
interpretation based on assumptions
assumptions that are not tangible
try bill see if you can find a practical
uh i
find one practical real world physical
demonstration that supports any globe
earth claim why are you not looking at
this objectively i have i have looked at
you know and and i keep
showing it but these people never show
up they never show up to question
or criticize what i put up there
so they just run away they do a hit and
run they just leave they never come back
and all they do is just say oh see you
cannot explain the water around the
earth you cannot explain the air around
the earth in a globe you know in the uh
global or
globular
earth
and i have and i've done it several
times i keep doing it but you know these
people never come back so only for those
people who
want to know what the answer is here it
is okay
uh we have here the earth the globular
earth the spherical earth more or less
spherical and what you have is all these
atoms they're known as water and they're
known as air
and all these atoms are tied to the
center of the earth by ropes
by electromagnetic ropes all atoms in
the universe are physically
interconnected so they all pull towards
the center of the earth
whether they're water or their air it
doesn't matter the reason they don't fly
away is because something is connecting
that atom to the atoms that make up the
earth
and of course the the only possibility
is a sphere and that's why all the
objects in the universe more or less are
spheres
because they all rely on gravity what is
gravity gravity means that all atoms are
physically interconnected physically
interconnected that's the only way you
can explain not only gravity but why
everything is roundish why everything is
uh spherical out there in the universe
okay
so yeah uh
you know i get sick and tired of
explaining this over and over again
these people never come back because
they came back these guys and they would
say okay i see what your point is first
they have to understand it and they
never come back so
of course they never understood it all
they do is just gripe
and of course one of the things that a
flat earther will always do and say that
we never went out into space
because if
we show them that you know we got
pictures from outer space of the earth
well that destroys their whole argument
so they have to deny that we ever went
into outer space they say no that's a
hoax that's uh
you know that's uh just government
feeding you nonsense
so how do satellites work i mean how
does your phone work they say a little
string you know stretching from england
all the way to you know newfoundland uh
underwater they think we're still in the
in the wire age poor people
okay anyways continuing here uh bill you
keep on attacking math yeah but we keep
on seeing phi the golden ratio
in nature's design so surely math has a
place in explaining our universe
well math only describes all you all phi
is whatever that
is it's just a description you haven't
explained anything so you need to
understand the difference between a
description which is what math does and
science which is explanations
explanations uh are not descriptions
descriptions are not explanations you
can explain a mechanism and math doesn't
do that math can't do that has no power
whatsoever to explain
math can only describe an equation is
only a description
okay that's why the mathematicians
converted science into or math into
science they say math and science are
synonyms because that's all we can do
and it's objective because uh math is
objective
yeah because math is a language is a
tautology what's on one side of the
equal sign is the same as the other
what's on the other side
so math is a tautology that's all of
relations
and all those are just descriptions
any equation any formula any
uh you know
number out there is only a description
all you're doing is describing something
you haven't explained anything with that
you cannot tell me what exists out there
in the invisible intangible world of
mother natures
you cannot tell me what causes gravity
because you can't see gra
the mediator of gravity
by doing math by doing equations and
that's the problem so what have the
mathematicians done they said well
math is the real science and everything
else is opinion
and now it's the other way around math
is just the language of descriptions
science is explaining that's what
physics does physics
rational explanations of mechanisms okay
okay so another foul along the same line
says oh let's not burn at the stake the
straw man we create out of
mathematicians
and their technologies i may not be a
scientist but i know science when i see
it
well you must have pretty good eyesight
because you can't see science okay but
anyways uh no mathematicians and
technologists they're not scientists
anyone who does experiments is known as
a technician a gopher lab boy
what is a mathematician guy who knows a
language just like there are people who
know chinese
greek etc well this guy knows a language
known as mathematics that's what it is
it's a language of relations
language of adverbs
only only adverbs that's all that
mathematics has what is a scientist
nothing to do with what's on the left
side there
a scientist is someone who explains
something he's got to explain a
mechanism primarily all the invisible
intangible mechanisms out there gravity
uh
magnetism light
electricity and so on
so that's what a scientist is a
physicist okay
okay so you gotta explain something if
you want to do science otherwise you're
not a scientist and if you did
equations look great great for you all
you did was a language uh you could put
it in chinese also and say okay uh this
equals that you could put it in words
and all you did was describe you haven't
explained anything
okay and fell says we can prove fields
physically exist just by observation
okay
so he says uh well you look up the word
field let's see it says a value for each
point in space and time
so uh how can you observe
values
in space and time
what are you observing what are you
seeing you got special eyesight maybe
and then uh nevertheless you know proof
uh proof is into pudding you know
one fellow there says proof is what
whiskey has right
persuading convincing urging someone to
convert to your beliefs that's all that
proof is so we don't prove in science
that's in religion you're doing religion
not science and so yeah we don't prove
fields first because we don't prove in
second because you can't observe fields
like you know with your two eyes
so no don't strain your eyes you won't
be able to see a field because there's a
bunch of numbers okay
value at each point in space and time
that's how field is
okay another foul says
how do you how do ropes explain
gravitational attraction unless the
ropes are elastic like rubber bands if
the ropes are elastic how far can they
stretch before they break
well now they don't stretch
uh
obviously has not watched enough of this
channel to understand but there it is in
a nutshell
nothing stretches because if the
ropes or the threads really stretch you
would be creating matter from
vacuum
where would the slack come from
so the the thread is made of a single
piece okay it's all the matter in the
universe just uh this thread winding
around from atom to rope broke to adam
and the rope rope to atom
and it's a single piece it doesn't
stretch and the way we produce gravity
is every atom in the universe is
connected to all other atoms through the
rope okay there's a twine pair of
threads between any two atoms and uh
what you see there is that the farther
two atoms are apart from each other
uh but really two objects made of many
atoms right
they are far apart from each other
then uh all the ropes uh come closer to
each other and they act almost as one as
a single coaxial the closer the two
objects come to each other the ropes fan
out
okay so acceleration of gravity is
simply the um fanning out of the ropes
that's in a nutshell you can look up uh
other uh videos that i've made out there
and even the book there's a book there
free book downloadable book uh the rope
hypothesis you can find it in my website
that's in the description
okay uh phil says um
last issue here he says could you
explain how the different atomic
substances the elements you know the
elements of the periodic table are
accounted for in the rope hypothesis
model
okay and so all i can answer to this
gentleman is
that is the subject
of next time around on wednesday i'll be
talking about that and so
i'll answer your question then